Now let's do Part b).
Find the average velocity of the particle for the time period between time 0 and time 6.
So the easy way to think about this, average velocity, is that your
average, or one way to think about it, the distance that you
travel, sometimes I use "d" for distance or "s" for displacement
But your distance in general is equal to your average
velocity times time.
Or, your average velocity is equal to the distance
you travel, divided by time.
And so how do we figure out the distance that we travel
over that period?
Especially because they didn't explicitly give us
the position function.
Well if you think about it,
Let's think about the velocity function over here
which they did give us,"v(t)"
and I don't know exactly what it looks like,
let me just draw a general velocity function right over here
So this is our t-axis,
and this is our velocity axis right over here
and we care about between time 0 and time 6,
and let's say our function does something like this,
it doesn't really matter, this is just a general drawing
over here, How do we figure out the total
distance over that time?
Well, if you take any small time,
right over here,and you multiply it
times roughly the constant velocity over that
time period, then that will tell you the area of
this little column, which will tell you
approximately, the distance traveled
over this very small interval of time.
Because you have time times an approximately
constant velocity, which will give you a
distance.
And so in general if you take the area
under this curve, from 0 to 6,
that will give you the total distance
travelled.
So "d" is equal to the definite integral
from 0 to 6 of "v(t)"
of this thing right over here,
"v(t)dt"
So if you want the average velocity,
you just find the distance, which is
this definite integral, and then
you divide that by the time, or the
elapsed time, in this case,
I could actually write times delta t
right over here, our change in time
right over here, is going to be 6
we start at 0 and we finish at 6, so we
just have to evaluate this
definite integral, which is not that easy to evaluate
analytically, it's lucky for us that
they do allow us to use calculators in this part
so we'll evaluate it using a calculator
And then we just have to divide it by 6
So let's first find out teh distance
travelled between time 0 and time 6.
And to do that,
we can use the TI-85
We'll go to catalog,
this tells us all of the different
functions they have.
And to evaluate definite integrals, we use the